here's another diverse person uh from
the new york post amy schneider's
jeopardy winning streak has finally come
to an end
last week the 42 year old made history
when and i'm reading i'm just reading
the language
from this article
otherwise
i wouldn't be choosing this language
myself last week the 42 year old made
history when she
won her
39th game and became number two on the
game show's consecutive win lease
winning list and the winningest woman of
all time but her time at the top ended
wednesday when she lost to uh ron tulsma
a librarian from chicago
and
lots of jokes can be made here and have
already been made so i'm late to it
saying maybe the final category was what
is a woman it wasn't the final category
was countries of the world
and um and then uh now schneider trails
only ken jennings
74 wins on the long-running game shows
consecutive wins list
but she quote unquote is now uh the the
number one champion
woman contestant of all time
and the second place
uh woman
trying to find her on here there was a
quote maybe i cut it off the second
place woman who's really the first woman
she she the actual she congratulated the
fake she
for you know supplanting her as the the
top female jeopardy contestant of all
time
because that's what she has to do
do you think the the woman who actually
is the best female jeopardy contest of
all time do you think she's happy about
this
that her place has been taken from her
by a man
no but she has to pretend that way you
know with today's inflation we all need
to be finding ways to save money on
things that we use every day ever wonder
how to strike the best deals and save it
to 90 on brand new items without even
needing to leave your home best of all
we'll look no further than dealdash one
of the leading auction sites in the
united states with over a decade in the
business whether you're in the market
for a basic kitchen appliance or a
luxury upgrade to your old tv whatever
you want deal dash will allow you to get
the best deals on whatever you're
looking for deal dash has hundreds of
auctions
daily on brand new items ranging from
tvs and laptops to tools and kitchenware
even cars with guaranteed free shipping
all auctions start at zero dollars and
you have a 90-day money-back guarantee
on your first
bid pack purchase you can use deal dash
both online at dealdash.com as well as
through our ios and android apps game
mechanics are simple all auctions start
at zero dollars each bid raises the
final auction price by one cent and
resets the clock to 10 seconds after the
10 seconds run out the final bidder wins
and can claim the auction win by paying
the final price don't be made victim to
today's inflation get all of the new
products you desire without the price
hikes at deal dash today use promo code
walsh for an additional 100 free bids
when making your first bid pack purchase
and start bidding now so now she's the
top uh
now she's number two and and the man is
number one for for female
contestants
and
you know i have to just complain about
this again because the new york post
i guess would consider itself to be a
just kind of mainstream media outlet
but i've read
plenty of articles in supposedly
conservative outlets about
this story about amy schneider
and
in the vast majority of them
even these conservative outlets are
using the preferred pronoun for
amy schneider for for calling a man a
woman
and they do this as i've complained
about many times
they do this many of these conservative
outlets even while pretending to oppose
this
they'll report on leah thomas over at uh
university of pennsylvania crushing the
female competition
and report on it in a negative way like
this is a bad thing
female sports are being destroyed by
this everything else
and yet they'll still use the preferred
pronoun
i've read plenty of commentary pieces by
conservatives saying this is terrible
females women's sports are under attack
because of people like leah thomas
she is crushing the competition well do
you see you've just destroyed your
argument you've you've surrendered the
point it's over now
the moment you agree
with the language you choose to use the
moment that you agree that this in fact
is a woman
it's what is what are you arguing about
just
immense cowardice even among
conservatives
and i i use that i use that phrase
conservative uh very very loosely i
think we need to put we need to put
scare quotes around that like we do
around she when talking about amy
schneider or leah thomas
because this is not just compromising
with the left this is not you
there's plenty of that has happened
in recent years
but this is you adopting far far left
radical ideas
and not just far left radical ideas but
far left radical ideas about basic facts
of
existence you are you are adopting their
premise
in the most extreme ways
about basic facts of reality
the moment you do that you're on their
side i don't care what else you have to
say
i don't care what your other positions
are
i would go so far as to say i i don't
you could be strongly in favor of of gun
rights you could be anti-immigration
you don't like
high taxes small government all that
kind of stuff
you could even call yourself pro-life
and go to the march for life
but if you're going to start calling a
man a woman
then you're on the left
because you have agreed with their
version of reality
and it's a version of reality where you
know all of their other
ideological
points
sprout from that this is this is the
root here
and everything else is a branch from
that root
because leftism is all about relativism
it's the worship of the self
that's why this gender stuff is so
important to them
because they want to establish
that reality itself is subject to an
individual's whims if i feel a certain
way i can change reality
reality will change itself according to
my whims
if you agree with that
by calling a man a woman because that's
what they want to be called
then you've given up the whole game
you are in no
coherent way a conservative at that
point
what are you conserving
i think there's there are many things
that need to be conserved in this
culture but to begin with we have to
conserve reality if we're not conserving
that then
then we lose everything
so you can't say okay i'll give up
reality but i really care about gun
rights
well good for you
go to antifa meeting and tell them about
that
you're not on our side well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content